if whatever reason you don't support the
current thing and you don't get either
vaccinated or whatever it is that money
can be programmed to work against you so
during the height of and the pandemic
many people who are unvaccinated weren't
allowed to go in certain shops so
instead of doing that with a central
bank digital currency because it's
programmable that level of
discrimination becomes far more
efficient and also if we look at the the
economics of this during times of
economic uncertainty um central banks
like to print more money in order to
stimulate the economy they need that
money to change hands but we could get
to a point where because this central
bank digital currency is programmable um
that money could essentially expire so
the central bank will say to you we need
you to spend the money so if you don't
spend let's say 10 of what you have in
your bank account in the next three
months that money is going to expire
that's your hard money that you that
you've earned is going to expire but of
course charles they're doing it to
protect you so they can stimulate the
economy very dangerous central bank
digital currencies are more efficient
enslavement machines